this episode is sponsored by audible to
get started go to audible.com slash
micro cosmos for text micro cosmos to
500 500
[Applause]
the micro cosmos surrounds and engulfs
invisible to us until we peer through
the lens of our microscope to witness
the incredible diversity of life at what
seems like the smallest of scales but
there are much much smaller scales than
this creating a kind of sub micro cosmos
and while you may find some
exceptionally tiny life here this is
also the realm of viruses existing in
their own limbo between what we consider
living and nonliving viruses are built
of packaged genetic material just like
any living cell but unlike microbes and
our own cells viruses lack the ability
to replicate that genetic material so
instead they infect relying on their
hosts to take in their genetic material
and follow their instructions to make
more virus while there are some large
viruses like the amoeba infecting mega
viruses that can get as large as 750
nanometers
most are much much smaller for context
the little crystals you see illuminated
at the tip of this cluster ium are about
two microns or two thousand in Anna
metres long that's almost three times
the size of the largest mega virus and
almost 17 times the size of most corona
viruses so it is difficult to see
viruses with the equipment we have on
hand but this sub micro cosmos has a
long reach extending into the micro
cosmos and as well into our own world so
for today I want to talk more about some
of the ties that bind across scale
[Music]
let's start with one example of how
viruses shape life in the micro cosmos
these Paramecium verse aria are very
very green they get that color
thanks to hundreds of little green algae
called chlorella that are housed in
vacuoles this relationship between the
Paramecium and its internal algae is an
example of endosymbiosis and when we see
examples of endosymbiosis
in the micro cosmos it's easy to focus
on what the larger microbe is getting
out of the relationship the green algae
are photosynthetic which makes them a
great internal nutrition provider to the
Paramecium but symbiosis is a
complicated relationship to maintain the
chlorella have to be housed in a special
peri algal vacuole membrane and the
Paramecium can control the number of
chlorella based on how much light there
is or based on when the Paramecium is
getting ready to divide so why would the
algae agree to all of this well
protection the micro cosmos as we've
seen is full of predators both small and
a little less small but just as
worrisome to the chlorella are the
viruses particularly the ficon Avira die
a group of large DNA viruses that target
eukaryotic algae from this group
chlorella are particularly susceptible
to two types of viruses called nc6 4a
and PB I look once you get down to these
scales nobody's thinking of creative
names anymore but when they're inside
the Paramecium the chlorella are safe
it's like the Paramecium is a kind of
fence keeping the algae in and the
viruses out these viruses only target
the chlorella when they are released
from the safe confines of the Paramecium
of course viruses are also crafty
scientists studying chlorella viruses
found that they were able to wait along
the surface of Paramecium burse area
most likely binding to receptors that
keep them anchored to the microbe these
videos were produced by the researchers
using confocal microscopy and
fluorescent stains the big red blobs you
see are actually the chlorella
chloroplasts distributed around the
Paramecium and making their own red
autofluorescence the green dots are
produced by adding a stain that binds
the DNA of dead cells showing us
potential locations for the virus along
the outside of the cell if the
Paramecium dies for whatever reason the
chlorella inside of them get released
and now not only is the chlorella 'z
protector gone its membrane is lined
with the very thing the algae was trying
to evade terrifying the goal for viruses
is to infect to find something that will
make more of them sometimes they're
looking to infect an algae sometimes
they're looking to infect one of our own
cells and in a way you can think of our
skin the same way chlorella might see a
Paramecium it's the initial line of
defense against pathogens like viruses
protecting the many cells inside us
there are other ways that viruses infect
us but in addition to our own body's
defenses humans have created a very
simple but powerful tool for dealing
with pathogens one that we didn't even
realize was so powerful until a few
centuries ago soap beautiful beautiful
soap
so has been around for many many
millennia made from various oils and
alkali the goal was cleanliness whether
of objects or of a person's own body but
it wasn't until the mid 1800s that a few
doctors began to realize that washing
their hands kept their patients safer
and healthier but even as we began to
understand more about microbes and
people continue to push for soap as a
way to contend with pathogens it wasn't
until the 1980s that anyone established
some sort of national hand-washing
guideline for hospitals so what is so
magic about soap and washing your hands
well some of it is just the movement of
it all of water and friction scrubbing
away at things that you might not even
be able to see but part of the power of
soap is simple chemistry we can't really
demonstrate the effect of soap on
viruses because as we said earlier we
don't really have the equipment to
showcase them so we're gonna use
bacteria as a proxy instead for a simple
experiment while bacteria and viruses
are different in a number of ways they
also share one very important trait
these bacteria were obtained most
professionally from the saliva of some
very cute kittens named Lupin and Sirius
that's right we swapped our kitties the
membranes of these bacteria are made up
of lipids which have a phosphate head
which dissolves in water and two fatty
acid chain tails that don't the
structure of this membrane is built on
keeping these fatty acid chains away
from the water that is both inside and
outside the bacteria that creates what's
called the lipid bilayer and while
viruses aren't technically living they
can find themselves reliant on a similar
chemistry their genetic material is
enclosed in a protein capsid and then
for many viruses that capsid is coated
with a viral envelope
that like the bacterial membrane is made
up of a lipid bilayer soap has a
structure similar to these lipids with a
fatty acid tail that wants to avoid
water and as we pipette diluted liquid
soap onto the sample those hydrophobic
tails also want to avoid water some do
this by attempting to break into the
bacteria's lipid bilayer ultimately
breaking up the membrane entirely others
form bubbles called micelles around bits
of bacteria and other debris of course
we can't see these little chemical
disruptions in action that's a far too
small a scale what we do see is the
bacterial colony quickly melting away
[Music]
our own cells also have lipid bilayers
but we can wash our hands without them
completely dissolving away into nothing
because our skin is a complex
combination of protein and cells that
protects us instead the soapy water
destroys and carries away the microbes
that cover them making it safer to eat
and to touch and whatever else you might
be using your hands for viruses are
tricky
they're so small and so capable of
adaptation so sometimes you have to hide
out like an algae and other times you
can rely on the basic chemistry of soap
but these are only two examples of the
many many strategies that have evolved
in nature or been developed by humans to
contend with the enormous impact that
viruses can have on our lives nothing in
this world is so small that we cannot
find a way to understand it and nothing
is so large that we cannot seek to
confront it thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us and thank you as
well to audible for supporting this
episode
there are many Mario books about the
micro cosmos that are available on
audible author Daniel coiin explains in
the tangled tree how recent discoveries
in molecular biology can change our
understanding of evolution and life's
history and that is yes available as an
audio book on audible
we here at journey to the micro cosmos
know that seeing the world in different
ways opens us up to new ideas and new
ways of thinking and we know that
compelling stories have the ability to
do that same thing if you go to the link
in the description you can listen to the
tangle tree along with many audible
originals which are exclusive audio
titles created by celebrated
storytellers from the worlds of sci-fi
journalism literature and more get your
first audiobook for free plus unlimited
audible originals when you try out
audible for 30 days by visiting
audible.com slash
micro cosmos or texting micro cosmos 2
500 500 the people on screen right now
those are our patrons on patreon it's a
place where you can go and support the
content that you love so that it will
continue existing so thanks to all of
them
for helping make this continue to happen
what great folks if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
check out Jam and germs on Instagram and
if you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
you